this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house
what's happening you bad [__]
yes it is it's monday
the 7th of march a beautiful
[__] monday and the joint is
brought to you by
liquid iv listen when you're working out
you want the best the best equipment the
best routine now liquid iv is here to
give you the best hydration i they've
been sponsoring the show for a few
months when i got covered i started
drinking a liquid iv and it changed my
life one stick of liquid iv and 16
ounces of water hydrates faster than
water alone
whether the grape
the
cherry is tremendous
the passion fruit is tremendous
made with premium ingredients liquid iv
is vegan non-gmo and free of gluten
dairy and soy i hate that [__] anyway
and now they also support frontline
workers to stay healthy liquid iv has
donated to hospitals
ems's food banks and veterans and active
military with over 19 million servings
donated listen to me
liquid iv is tremendous it's available
nationwide at
costco
a little pricey what i'm going to do for
you is i'm going to get you 25 off when
you go to liquidity.com and use code
joey at checkout can you believe that 25
off on a monday morning when you order
promo code joey and liquidive.com
promo code joey experience the best
hydration today with
liquidity.com promo code joey and now
without further ado
to join on a monday morning
[Music]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
so
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 7th of [__]
march a beautiful [__] day to be
alive i had a great weekend things are
going on the ufc was great
uh
last week was a weird week for me
because i finished the [__] book the
week before
so
guys for the last 14 months this book
has you know kept me
busy a couple nights you know you have
to sit down and outline and look at
the previous outline and see what you
want to add to it
so like i tell you guys you know at
night i like to watch tv with my wife my
daughter but
at one point i just turned the tv off
and i would outline this and it would be
like three nights a week sometimes on
the weekends but it was my job for the
time being you know
and the last two weeks i haven't been
doing that [__]
so
this week early on the week i'm like
what the [__] going on in my life i'm
so [__] bored
you know i'm [__] bored to pieces
here and it was like monday and tuesday
i had errands you know i got my regular
[__]
but something was missing all week and
i'm like [__]
this sucks
and by friday i was having a rough
[__] day like friday afternoon guys
we have good days and we have bad days
and my day was just not going well
and uh
my phone went off and it was one of my
buddies from the eighth grade david ruiz
great guy
we hooked up like in the sixth grade and
he's like hey man what are you doing
this weekend
you know i could uh
i'd go out saturday night if you're
available and i was like
you know what man my wife
and i was just about to make an excuse
that my wife was out of town or whatever
and i don't know
let's [__] do it
let's do it i go let's do this let's
start simple
let's go for a nice [__] steak
let's meet at steakhouse 85 in new
brunswick right over there at 85 church
street across from the stress factory
that whole area i don't know if you ever
been to the stress factory if you ever
gonna go see a comic
at the stress factory do me a favor
spend the extra [__] 100 and go to
dinner and [__] new brunswick whether
it's the 85 which is [__] tremendous
rogan took me there maybe 15 [__]
years ago and it's been
nothing but great and the head chef
goes to gracie jiu jitsu with me so it's
[__] perfect it's perfect i didn't
see him friday he went on saturday i
went on friday i didn't go on saturday
so i never got a chance to talk to him
so
i i just wanted to salvage a night so it
was me and dave i called louis hernandez
you know my buddy was dominican but
moved to north bergen and everybody
would call him [__] racial epithets
and [__]
and
believe it or not he was in
and then i called my man whitey
because he's the one his wife was the
one that initiated this whole thing
and he's like
let me check and i'll hit you up
tomorrow and he hit me up that night
friday night he hit me up and goes i'm
[__] in
and i was like wow so we got the the
original foursome you know we're missing
like chucky and a couple of guys dominic
speciale rest of soul
so i go let's just start it off with
four of us why'd he call me back and he
goes i'm bringing my friend dominic i
said go ahead i remember dominic from
back in the day
and it's so weird like i've always told
you guys i i just saw this the other day
a video of me popped up on tick tock
like i don't subscribe to tick tock i've
never posted on tick-tock
yeah i'm all over tick-tock
and the other day i saw a tick-tock
video on twitter and it was just me
saying
you know you don't need all this [__] in
your life with three friends
you could conquer the [__] world did
you see that the other day
yeah and i'm like wow
that's crazy i forgot i even said that
[__] about your three friends
and when i saw that i go holy [__]
i gotta see my friends but i tell you
guys
friday was just i don't know it was like
uh
i was just down i even did a patreon
podcast and i talked about
that life you have your ups and downs
you know and that's a good thing that's
great about life that life doesn't
always suck and life isn't always great
can you imagine if when your life was
always great you wake up in the morning
a chick is sucking your dick you hit the
lotto what the [__] you know what i'm
saying after a month you're like i can't
do this no more people sucking my dick
and me winning money every day and me
having fun what the [__] can't my cat
get hit by a car or something like that
something you know
you know life isn't [__] per you know
but sometimes
so if my wife was gone i go [__]
let's go you know let's go and sure
enough saturday i woke up with
the joey diaz syndrome i woke up with
the regular
syndrome i don't know if i want to go
i don't feel good what if i get carsick
i mean i'm only [__] 20 minutes from
new brunswick how car sick can i [__]
get
so i got up yesterday i had honey nut
cheerios because i was gonna eat meat
anyway so i said no more yeah i prepare
honey nut cheerio like omar from the
wire that [__] keeps your cholesterol
down you know what i'm saying so i hit
some honey nut cheerio for breakfast
that was it and for lunch i had a peanut
butter and jelly sandwich homemade
tremendous a little jiff creamy stop it
walter's great from the [__] ah
tremendous
so i [__] uh i was prepared for last
night
about four o'clock
i popped like 600 milligrams in abx
edibles cause listen i'm not going to a
high-priced steakhouse and not gonna eat
you don't understand guys i don't have
the appetite i used to like like a
[__] chubby i don't have it no more i
can't even i order a 14-ounce steak half
of it comes home
and that's fresh from smoking a joint
the whole thing you just don't have it
no more
so i
i [__] it i go you know what i'm going
to prepare myself just in case i took
800 milligrams with me but i popped
three here
600 i popped three abx capsules and then
i had one left i put it in my pocket
just in case i need a little buffer
later on you know what i'm saying for
the right hole sometimes you got to get
the wing going so
i take my shower i wash my [__] and i
[__] uh drive up to new brunswick and
right away i [__] get in no problems
i you know i had the waves i got lost
even with the [__] wave app
i said make a left on lincoln and there
i was and i'll never forget i pulled in
there's a a
parking garage next to the stress
factory across the street from
steakhouse 85 and [__] the light
changed three times before i even got to
the [__] garage because that's how
busy it is a lot of people go out to
dinner in east brun and new brunswick
and
they have a lot of [__] going on they
have theater and plays it's a night you
know rutgers is there it's just a great
little [__] town you know so
i pull into the driving town i'm like
[__] i'm enough to walk up to the fourth
floor
i can see all the cars but as i have
uncle joey's pulling in
i see these spots three of them are wide
open they go 30 minute parking only
[__] you i pulled right into that i
ain't walking up there i pulled right
into the 30 minute park you know and as
i got out there was a chick there with
the car to give tickets
but i [__] didn't even look at it i
just kept walking i got to make it in
there and i walked in and the lady goes
how are you i go great i'm here meet my
friends last name is diaz and she goes
already at the [__] bar i was like
god damn
walked over there and we [__] almost
broke down right there my legs were
going soft on me
when louie hugged me and dave hugged me
it was [__] insane and i posted them
huh
35 years
i did not see them from 1985 not a
comedy show because they're not on
social media these guys
so they live by their kids their kids
would tell them coco's coming and they
would always tell them too late
but the one guy's sister would come see
me
and i would always exchange messages for
him with her you know
but it was so weird to sit at a table
with these dudes
you got to remember there was five of us
three of us
me louie and dave were in the same
eighth grade
and seventh grade class
how [__] crazy is that
as soon as we sat down i could see that
everybody was a little kind of like it
was surreal
dave my friend dave was
he was struggling with it
and i can feel for him but you also
gotta remember i knew these three these
these guys knew my mother
that's what made this dinner even more
special they would come to my house all
the time play basketball go swimming my
mom would cook rice and beans for them
and [__] steaks and [__] and they
were all talking about my mom last night
that they were all they were [__]
hysterical stories about my mom and my
mom would tell them to shut the [__] up
we had a kid lifting at my house one day
and he put a lot of weight on he kept
saying i know i know now he had like a
[__] up chin as it was like marlon
brando but when he went in my backyard
my mom was on the phone looking out the
door like what are these guys doing
we're in the backyard we got a bench out
in the backyard
and we're bench pressing and [__] and
it's lucio's turn he's one of the
commissioners up in union city now and
we he starts throwing on i don't know if
you guys don't remember
weights used to be plastic with cement
inside
so
the [__] weights were like half built
the concrete was falling off they were
old weights we're like 13 we're trying
to be [__] bodybuilders we're putting
[__] weights on there lucio's like
put more weight on for me put more
weight on for me so he grabs the [__]
bar and also he goes he lifts it up and
it just goes straight down like it
didn't even you know you hold the bench
like ah help he it just went right and
it went right down and hit him in the
chin
so we picked it up he's like ah ah so my
mom will call him the chin after that
put some ice on the chin and then every
time you come over my mind would go the
chin lucky hot in spanish
we were talking about all that [__] but
it was just
it was surreal that
we had the bond that we had i tried to
tell you guys that this was gonna happen
about six months ago
i said watch guys i'm gonna connect with
my grammar school buddies and that's
gonna be the beginning of me it's gonna
change me because i'm back to where i
was
you know i was older than these guys
but if you remember i got left back in
the seventh grade
the seventh grade year i got left back
on
i played basketball when i wasn't any
good
and then the year i got left back
i was [__] embarrassed these guys
never made fun of me they never called
me stupid they never said nothing
the year i got left back i felt so bad
in the seventh grade and i just
disappeared
i joined the basketball team i was going
to karate again
and i was just trying to get my life
together i was [__] humiliated that i
got left back
[__] humiliated i sat in that class
the first month and i was just so
[__] uncomfortable
and i thought i was gonna [__] die
and next thing you know these guys just
you know i always knew dave
see before i moved to
the mckinley area in north bergen i
lived in the mecca i'm sorry i had lived
in the mckinley area of north bergen
when i first moved there and i was still
going to parochial school in kearney and
carnegie new jers
i didn't hang out with north bergen
people but i did
when i would go to my mother's bar it
was on 29th and bergen line i would walk
down to the 26th street projects in
north bergen
and that was my introduction really to
north bergen that was a complete
different world down there
we were talking about last night the
carvajals the [__]
the martin perez martin perez's father
was [__] one of the guys in batista's
army so i told you guys that when they
landed in
north bergen they were okay but then the
word got out that this guy lived in
north bergen
so [__] they came after him to kill
him so the feds had to take martin perez
so all of us ran down there at that time
it was me
david ruiz martin perez
armando dean lapreet just so many
[__] and we were always
up to no good we were always stealing
light bulbs from [__] duratest and
hitting each other on the heads with it
we would fill [__] socks with flour
and beat the [__] out of each other we'd
have flour all over us
i mean this wouldn't there was no drugs
there was no thievery involved and
somewhere along the line i became
friends with david ruiz and this kid
named armando rudy
and these guys were a blast you know
like
i don't know if you guys remember this
being young and having that crew that
you talked about sex with like all the
things you were gonna do to a girl when
you had the opportunity that was this
crew
that was this seventh grade crew we
would just
sit there for hours and talk about how
we're gonna make out with these girls
and
[__] have a corvette we would we were
we were a [__] a dollar away from
having a quarter you know what i'm
saying like everybody was broke and
we're talking all this nonsense and [__]
so i became friends with dave dave was a
great basketball player there was courts
over there by senator ford that's not
center forward anymore that's what i
used to do punt pass and kick
but there were these tremendous courts
on 26th street tremendous little hidden
behind center forward and that center
forward where they used to do the punt
passing kick it was [__] tremendous
and if you walked across the bridge on
route 3 we made it over to the other
side to mckinley so we had all that
you had this whole area to [__] play
with i still remember walking over that
bridge with a with a walkman on and
stepping on caterpillars
there was millions of caterpillars on
this bridge and you know caterpillars go
into a cocoon they turn into a butterfly
or some [__] and i'm [__] walking on
this bridge and i'm stomping it's early
in the morning by myself i'm just
stomping these [__] caterpillars bye
you can hear them crunch
my sneakers all green and [__] and i
kept walking and all of a sudden
some kid came running up behind me just
like that to my ears
dawg i must have jumped eight feet in
the air i thought it was one of the
caterpillars that had jumped out my back
and [__]
i mean we were doing something every day
now
in the seventh grade something really
weird happened
that kid juan moved over from the bronx
puerto rican kid he was a tremendous
basketball player while he was moving
getting his furniture in and out of the
bronx i wanted his house and we stole
his [__] me and my buddies on giving
that terrace i got the stereo and the
speakers in my room long story so now
we're looking like holy [__] we got
chucky as the point guard we got david
ruiz
and the other puerto rican kid as the
forwards or maybe move [__] him up to
uh
a shooting guard and you got me and the
puerto rican who could jump
to play forwards now we gotta get a
center so that was our [__] plan
so
you know we played like maybe one game
and all of a sudden we're sitting in
[__] the seventh grade the kid walks
in with an afro
and he says his name is louis hernandez
and the first thing out of my thing was
dog
you got a julius or irving afro can you
play like him and he's like yeah i can
play
and i'm like oh thank god
we need this [__]
and louie came on the team and that
season we went [__] oh and seven
we were god awful we couldn't win a
[__] game
i was [__] heartbroken i had gotten
left back i didn't have a girlfriend no
more
i was [__] you know my life seemed
like it was in the [__] dumps
i was still going to karate i go you
know what man i don't ever want to be an
undefeated team ever [__] again
so me dave
louie we started a [__] campaign
of just constant basketball we were
always playing basketball the winter
the summer
and somewhere along that we recruited a
guy named whitey white he went to
kennedy school
nice irish kid great [__] family his
mother always made chicken cutlets his
grandfather was our [__] chauffeur we
could be and [__] move on the moon
and he would call his grandpa pop up i'm
stuck over here we just won we don't
know how to get home i'll be right over
and i'll bring chicken for you
[__] and he'd come bring his
chicken bring his gatorades
guys it was a [__]
dream come true and whitey played for
another school and there was no
animosity we got along like [__]
brothers i was at whitey's house three
nights a week
we had a bounce back i don't know if you
guys know what a bounce back is it's
like a [__] net it looks like a
camouflage net on a thing and you throw
the ball against it and it pushes it
back to you and we just sit there for
hours me and whitey and take foul shots
free throws we work on our jump shots
and then he could climb on the concrete
wall and slam dunk he was like
spider-man i could not do that i was
petrified to climb on the wall and slam
dunk and then we played after a few
hours and the coach from rampo college
when he was a kid he wasn't a coach yet
chucky mcbreen would call us and say
what are you guys doing come over to my
house and sleep over and we will walk
from downtown to 30th and patterson
plank road chucky had a dirt basketball
court a dirt basketball court every time
you [__] had dribbled the ball there
was dust all around you and [__] like
that you look like if you played three
games you were [__] filthy but he had
a pool and then we would jump in the
pool and you could see the dirt just
come off around you like there's six of
us dirty water we didn't give a [__] it
was all about basketball there was
nobody getting high
there was nobody stealing [__] yeah we
they were yeah we did a couple [__]
creepy things but nothing
we were very innocent kids at that time
guys very innocent
we lived for basketball i lived for
basketball and for karate that was my
whole i went to mckinley i got out i
went home i played with some north
bergen guys about 4 30 i got him
i got on my [__] feet i walked up the
hill take a bus to [__]
i don't know 16th
and uh palisade album i go to karate and
then from karate go to my mother's bar
eat dinner and go home that was my
[__] life that was it and when we
weren't in karate me and these other
lunatics were [__] at movie theaters
going to harlem
no drugs guys strip clubs [__] like that
no drugs just straight up kids
that's all we were
we were [__]
just straight-up kids in the eighth
grade
our bond got so [__] strong we're
going into the eighth grade we're like
[__]
we were always seven last year we got
louie raul the puerto rican dude he had
left already he moved after like four
months his father couldn't pay rent in
jersey it was too high rent across the
street they were used to the apartment
limit over in the bronx so he left so we
were left with me
david
chucky and we had a tremendous we had
dominic speciale
and anthony balzano go [__] god bless
both of their souls
we had a tremendous eighth grade [__]
team
i still remember
the last day of school
you go into the grade you're gonna go
into
and you meet your teacher
and the eighth grade teachers were miss
virga and miss walsh
both of them were older than old lady
time
both these women
were [__] way past that prime they
could not teach anymore but they were
good teachers they were older
and i'll never forget it was teacher
named miss verga and miss walsh we got
miss walsh me louie hernandez
orlando saucedo
dominic speciale we [__] had miss
walsh and the first day we went in there
she goes listen guys
class in particular has a reputation
and she goes i don't give a [__]
i really don't i'm not gonna play with
you guys i'm too [__] old
and i will throw you out of here one by
one like if she drew the [__] line
the first day like that it wasn't the
first day of school it was the last day
of school
she drew the [__] line with her she
was like here you know i'll [__]
suspend you
i'll throw you the [__] out and it was
like i was in the first row i had this
cat the sicilian uh imported he had been
in this country maybe two years from
italy
and his name was michael we used to play
street hockey and i would hit him in the
shins with the street hockey stick
because he couldn't speak english and
he'd go yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
whenever i hit him in the leg
and that's all he did he was an italian
kid [__] off the charts book off this
off the books smart we had this kid in
the back named orlando saucedo little
chubby [__] dominic's bishop sat
on the other side of class
and our job was to [__] torment miss
walsh we can't listen when she drew the
line with us the last day of school that
gave us all summer to think about ways
to torture this [__] lady and when we
get back into the eighth grade at the
end of the summer we're all basketball
machines i had been to [__]
superstar basketball camp down there in
jersey city with the [__] hurleys i
mean we were basketball machines that's
all i gave a [__] about a girl broke my
heart i was never going for [__] again
that [__] hurts too much when you're in
eighth grade in the seventh grade with
some chick break your heart
it just hurts a little too much i was
like [__] this [__]
it's not about [__] no more it's just
gonna be about [__] sports
we get into the [__] in eighth grade
it's great
first day of school ms verga the other
teacher announced to her class
that she was taking medical leave
that she had over the summer they had
fine they had found the tumor
and they were going to operate on her
and it was going to take 8 to 12 weeks
to recuperate
and then a substitute was going to be
named so that [__] this all up we
already had a plan to torture welsh and
very good now we got to think of a whole
new [__] strategy it's like the
[__] she didn't make weight you have
a fighter that doesn't make weight or he
catches covert now you got to find a
whole new opponent and we're like what
the [__] are we are we going to torture
her in those days
we went to homeroom miss walsh and you
probably stayed with miss walsh for
maybe 45 minutes and then the bell went
off and you went to miss verga for a
period and then you went to the seventh
grade because they probably thought like
history over there and then you went to
mr king walk because he taught like math
or some [__]
and that was our [__] day then the
whole afternoon you'd spend it
with your eighth grade teacher or your
regular homeroom teacher
so this was our goal every [__] day
we'd stay in school till 12.
once that bell went off we'd run out of
there me orlando dominic and we run up
the shop right on right off route 3
there
we'd go in there and we'd [__]
shoplift
every piece of gum we could juicy fruit
hubba bubba double mint
you [__] name it we [__] stole it
after a few after a few weeks we decided
to
the [__] uh
the wintergreen and all that gum
wouldn't hit you hard enough like you i
had to put like six pieces of [__]
juicy fruit to get like a good piece of
gum to whip at you
but with hubba bubba all i gotta do is
put two or three pieces in my [__]
mouth and i got a little snowball i got
a little [__] weapon so we would go
up to the [__] shop right and steal
that 10 packs of hubba bubba down our
pants security knew we were stealing
they'd chase us out of every [__]
damn we'd have to run
down the hill every once a month once a
month somebody got caught
and we get back to class and they're
like don't say nothing somebody would
get caught and [__] so
by this time we're [__] rolling hubba
bubba all of us
girls included and we're getting a piece
and we're just whipping it at one
another in the classroom
so we got miss walsh down to a science
we would behave in the mornings we would
go to lunch get rushed up and then come
back at 12 45 and proceed to torch that
lady
till three o'clock
first there was an array of noises you
know
orlando would go wow
wow
they would read in the afternoons and he
would sit in the back going wow
wow
[Applause]
she would just look up and look around
the class to see who was doing
and it
michael alex the immigrant
could make some noises like he used to
go
he did like a haunted house so now we
had
oh we had these two noises in the mix
so you had
but he would do it loud and then i'll
land on the back going wow
wow and then i would start
with my walls over here right wow
wow and she'd be looking up and she'd be
looking around and a piece of gum would
fly in the [__] room and she would
look at the wall and go what the [__]
was that
and then
some afternoons we just said [__] it we
would put pieces of paper in our mouths
a whole piece of paper
and [__]
get spit balls that were so big
and whip them at the wall they would hit
and the spit would come out of them and
[__] they were so disgusting i mean this
is what we did every day and she would
have to take a breather she'd go okay
now we're just gonna sit until you guys
get over it and then we'd go heavy for
like 10 minutes
we'd make animal noises and [__]
and then she got you guys ready to
proceed and we go yeah and then we
[__] be quiet for like 30 minutes and
then bring it on home for the last 45
minutes of class thought we would make a
cry she was leaving there
[__] up remember half of the kids that
half of us had trained under a guy named
john barone
that it might we were talking about last
night and my world was a phenomenal
teacher and one of the funniest [__]
human beings around so we had all been
in the seventh grade baron
our sense of humor
had been taken a [__] notch by barone
barone opened it up
our sense of humor so [__] much and
that class was very freeing barons for
example there was a kid in the class
named richie columbo
richie columbo
didn't give a [__]
do you understand me people
do you understand you have like little
friends or like these girls that go to
yoga and they're like i don't care you
know
okay yeah good
good yeah you ever see these guys like i
don't care okay good
listen richie carmo
didn't give a [__] in the eighth grade
to the point where he wouldn't even comb
his head
he had like this [__] nest
and he would come in and mr brown would
look at him and just shake his head and
one day baron couldn't take it no more
and bro goes hey columbo
what you comb your hair with a stick of
dynamite
and colombo goes nah would you comb that
mop on your [__] head with i mean
this was our 7th grade class okay we had
charlie gizzy
who sat by the window and every time a
plane went by he jumped on his desk and
he machine gun it down okay
okay do you understand me guys this is
not a jokey joke [__] eighth grade
class then the other half of these
[__] were 16 17 there were
cubans that came from this country and
would not speak english so they kept
leaving them back
they would drive to school they had
beards they had kids at other school i
mean it was [__] you know these cuban
guys like 18 with two kids hair on their
legs you know you're like what the [__]
i'm in the eighth grade i got three
hairs on my dick and you're in gym
changing with a guy that's got a [__]
an arab for a [__] he's got [__] you
don't see those arab beards that's what
he's got around his dick it looks like a
neck brace for his [__] dick i mean
it was [__] it was just we had
another kid we had gizzy we had douglas
geminis another guy didn't give a [__]
with long hair he was just looking to
get out of school and start a [__]
band
and dog listen i saw the principal leo
gattoni
get punched in the face by louis saldwa
one day and [__] in the eighth grade
louis aldebaran punched him in the face
that mr tony's leg buckled in the
hallway as he was taking him to the
principal's office these guys are not
your regular [__] uh
nicey nice classroom okay we got
we got a teacher fight we got a gym
teacher fight
then uh a [__]
gym teacher hit me in the [__]
seventh grade you guys eighth grade you
guys forgot about that and anthony
balzano's father [__] came in
and cleaned this [__] clock and they
transferred them out
look this eighth grade was no joke guys
we didn't have a gym
you know how they judged us on gym we
had a shovel snow in the winter
next time you drive on route 3 and you
headed into the city look at that
[__] school
on the left that you can't see through
the windows that it's like the sun they
have like a sun block on there look at
those stairs
it's like five levels of [__] stairs
we got to shovel when we were [__]
kids and that that's a tough
[__] school jack that
school you know after i got thrown out
of [__] sacred art school for boys
i was like all right i guess i'll go to
school north bergen
doug my first day at mckinley one of the
teachers had to go home because she put
his lunch canteen
on the desk and somebody put ahead of
acid in his [__] coffee
in the sixth grade he was a sixth grade
[__] teacher a fifth grade teacher at
aggressor so that means summing the
fifth grade in that school but it hit a
window pane acid in this [__] canteen
and this [__] cooler the coffee thing
he never came back from lunch
and
then last night we were talking about
this we almost died at the table
because whitey went to kennedy but it
was me david
and uh
and louie at mckinley
and now by this time mrs walsh's class
it was like
october and we were just driving her
[__] nuts
miss verga was gone
we had a substitute teacher until they
found the right teacher and while they
were looking for the teacher they gave
us this guy named mr miss
mr miss was a good looking blonde dude
that looked like [__]
uh robert redford in the in the sting
whenever he would teach the girls would
go [__] nuts me and my buddies like
we got to kill mr [__] uh miss
because all the chicks like him it was
[__] crazy blonde head dude yolk
a nice guy really nice guy
but i'll never forget he came into the
school one day the substitute
when was very he had like a week at the
school and he was like guys
they talk about this class
and all the grammar schools
how people do not want to come to
school what do you people do to
substitutes
what the [__] you know like what are you
doing to i mean it was guys it was not
pretty
if you sat with us in the afternoons we
would torment you the noises the [__]
the riffraff it was just uh
it didn't stop
so i never forget
that we got to class one day it was like
a wednesday
and [__] uh mr miss comes in with
miss walsh
they're talking in the hallway we're
getting into class and also miss mills
miss
welsh and mr miss walk in they go guys
miss walsh has to say something to you
and she goes today we're getting a
visitor
i hope
you guys can behave because if you don't
we're not going to get any more visitors
they want to come and talk to you about
cookies or something like that we're
like okay
so they said about 9 15 we're going to
put two classes together that was no
bueno
they were going to put both our 8k class
together and this dude was going to do a
presentation
me louie was sitting in the classroom
and the guy comes out he's got big eyes
like one of those people that has like
those typewriters like hi good morning
students he goes i'm here to talk to you
about some disease
and we're like okay you know he wants to
talk to us about some childhood disease
and he's like uh you know he's given us
the pitch
that these kids they're born this way
and
the surgery takes like a week and then
they have to spend a year in a hospital
and this costs money and if you guys
sell these whatever i i would like to
say cookies i don't wanna i don't know
what he was trying to make us sell
but he was just closing on us right he's
like you don't understand this is gonna
you know help your school i'm gonna help
you guys and we're like what the [__]
guy and i mean i remember turning around
and everybody was looking at him like
you can't be [__] serious and he's
closing you know he's telling us all the
benefits
by selling this stuff and he goes you
don't understand
you guys will be helping kids he goes
let me he goes you guys you know how
lucky you are you guys could walk around
and play basketball and go to gym he
goes these kids it takes them
30 minutes to take three steps
and [__] richie colombo that dude
that mr brown with the head do he put
his hand up the guy's like i'm not done
yet
uh hold on with your question richie's
like
the guy's like what and he goes if these
kids it takes him 30 seconds 30 minutes
to take three steps
why don't you just give him roller
skates right that's all he said to this
dude
and this dude
looked at him
he goes that's it
presentation over i'll never forget this
and he went back to his suit briefcase
you know how they open up their
briefcase to go
and also the briefcase opens up he was
slamming his stuff in there and he's
like i never knew why i came to the
school they warned me against hughes
this is the worst school on the program
and all of a sudden we just started
throwing spit balls bubble gum paper it
was [__] surreal he was putting his
[__] hands up he ran out and that was
it they're like that's it for you
[__] then we got a substitute
teacher a full-time one his name is
wally lindsey he was the mayor of
weehawken he was coming to teach our
eighth grade
cool [__] long hair you know he
took us all out individually
hey listen i know all about you
[__] i'll break your [__]
neck
he goes i know this guy i know that guy
and they've already told me about you
[__] if i have any problems with
coco and anthony balzano i'm supposed to
call carmine balzano well like that's
cool
[__] you know that's cool so now we
got a connection
whatever baron and me hated each other
in the seventh grade now me and maroon
were best friends miss walsh
finally one day
we [__] went into we did our usual
[__] thing we went to shoprite we
came back and one afternoon we just went
off so hard
mike we went off so hard let people
guys you just never believe how hard we
went off on it
things were flying people were making
noises machine gun noises
it was just farts it was [__] awful
and in the middle of it she slammed her
book it was like two in the afternoon
she slammed her book
and she goes noises heavy breathing you
know she's like
yells screams gum
she goes what is this and one of the
kids goes meet the noise [__] and she
was like ah and she [__] ran out of
class crying
and the principal came in like 20
minutes late he's like guys i'm thinking
of breaking this class up
like breaking the whole eighth grade up
and sending these all
to different [__] schools
because this is not [__] working
just like that glasses from the wire
what
[Music]
she went outside she cried the principal
came in he said you had 30 days
to [__] turn around
or we're going to get broken up into
different classes this dog this is all
of us
and when she came back
we apologized to her
and we made her promise we none of those
guys wanted to see miss walsh cry she
was 60 something [__] years old
you know we didn't want to see her cry
so we just called the truce
and she said this is what i'll do when
you guys get back from lunch i'll let
you go off
for 20 minutes
and then we'll teach and that worked
that worked we came to a truce some were
great but then we got more bad news
dave ruiz came in one day and he goes
hey
my parents want to move to miami
to get a house for us for college and
all this [__] so i got to live with my
aunt downtown i'm transferring from
[__] mckinley to kennedy school who
like
we just went and killed ourselves to put
the perfect [__] team together
we just went on our way to put the
perfect [__] team together and now
you're going to leave so we started
calling them benedict arnold
we would tease them and [__] and listen
we were all happy for him
now the team was going to be me louie
chucky dominic speciale
and anthony balzano that was it we were
talking about this last night too about
the ref was anthony's cousin
so anthony's father called the ref and
told him not to call any more files on
this because he had a glass eye
you got to go
his name was peter capitoro
mr capitoro he was a ref he was like a
teacher at lincoln school and he was
[__] refereeing and he had a glass
eye his left eye was glass
so every time i'd be dribbling on the
right side of the court and i'd see him
on the left side i'd go close to him and
go dog stand in the right because you
can't see from there i mean we would
[__] torment them and [__] we that
this all happened in the eighth grade
guys
on friday nights we'd all meet on given
that terrace we'd buy
tons of sodas tons of potato chips i get
gino's pizza the one with like 50 pizzas
on the tray and you put them in the oven
their sausage pepperoni
little circles and [__] we were kids and
we'd all eat at my house and then
something happened to the way to the
[__] dance we decided one day
that maybe we're gonna give this
marijuana a try
it was in the eighth grade when all of
us were like man we want to smoke it but
we're scared we're athletes and [__] and
there were some people didn't do it but
me louie
and those were the nights i used to blow
the smoke into louise afro
we would smoke pot we
smoked tons of pot and then it you know
in those days when you smoked when
you're [__] in the eighth grade
and we were smoking like i don't know
green weed from the city at that time
there wasn't even green wheat it was
like brown wheat the weeds in the eighth
grade were panama red you know
gold all that [__]
but i still remember
going up to the [__] uh soccer field
shitzon park and getting like a nickel
bag from puerto rican nelson that's when
puerto rican nelson was in our lives the
pedophile from giving that terrorist
and he would sell us like seven joints
for five bucks
and i still remember going up to that
soccer field
and guys it would be
20 of us
you know all different shapes and sizes
and in those days you smoked six joints
between 20 people and you hallucinated
i'm not gonna lie to you guys that's how
tender we were as kids like i still
remember being behind there
drinking like a half a boons for him
and smoking like six joints
and sitting and looking at the moon like
wow i swear to god
like it
it's as plain as day for me
of all of us i remember us getting high
and [__]
following like car lights
like wow look at that light look look at
that one oh my god look at that like you
were like [__] enough it's a [__]
car light you [__] idiots but that's
how
i still don't being that [__] high
that it was that [__] strong the weed
and that intense and we'd have to go to
the [__] bowling alley and they had
chocolate milk
and we would get [__] three chocolate
milks a piece and [__] sandwiches and
[__] who would we get chocolate milk
and all our fries
that's how much money you had everything
was 50 cents for the chocolate milk and
75 cents for the fries you know what i'm
saying and if you have like three bucks
you got a [__] cheeseburger whoa
but
that's where our bond came from you know
in the eighth grade
and then
i still remember the opening season
opening game of the season was a friday
but there was also a dance at kennedy
school
we were talking about this last night we
were all bringing up different points
but
they were all going coco how do you have
this [__] memory this is crazy
we were talking about pat caputoro we
were talking about there was this so
the league was broken into
lincoln mckinley franklin and kennedy
school
franklin was number one they had two
forwards that were bigger than me
and their center was six foot five in
the eighth grade
the second team that was gonna come in
and project it was to be lincoln's uh
kennedy school kennedy school had david
and whitey o'donnell they had a good
[__] team man they were going to be
hard to beat
we had me louie chucky
lincoln had rhaego
fernie basisudo you know we were all
friends at that time we're all playing
against each other and look we all came
back to haunt each other later on in
life
and i'll never forget that we played
we beat lincoln
but when we got to the dance
they were telling us that the center
from franklin lee irwin
kennedy broke his ankle
kennedy school surrounded him and he
went to jump and they put their foot
under him when the guy landed it broke
his ankle he couldn't play for the
season
we were like relieved like holy [__] you
guys knocked kennedy out of the [__]
lincoln out of the [__] so we were
[__] ecstatic i remember
still going down there
to kennedy school and i still remember
after the dance what do you think we did
guys we think we snuck we went to a
liquor store no
we went right to the back of the
basketball court and we would play
kennedy school till 11 o'clock at night
that was our life there was no nothing
we knew nothing all we want to do is
play basketball we were talking last
night about how many times i would leave
my house
and given that terrorist and walk
to whitey's house like on ninth street
in two feet of snow
and then his grandfather would give us
shovels and we'd go to the basketball
court at kennedy and shovel not half
court [__]
the whole [__] court
and we'd be out there playing basketball
be 20 degrees the ball wouldn't even
bounce because the air freezes
and the ball the ball wouldn't even
[__] bounce
that's how [__] that's how much work
we were putting into [__] that's how
much work i had put into basketball with
these guys whatever white he ate i ate
whatever white he got i got whatever i
got
white he got david got louie got when i
would write letters to duke
and to get that workout programs when
bill foster or
you know somebody would send me their
workout from the schools i would make
copies on the xerox machine and i would
give them to these guys we all worked
out together you know how many times we
were talking about how many times you
played basketball and then go sit on a
wall to help our thighs so we could slam
dunk and we just have like we just sit
there like [__] for two [__]
hours staring at each other to see who
could sit there the longest this is
this is a friendship that uh
like i said
it took us six or seven minutes to warm
up last night
we got there all of us were there we
were at our table seated at six o'clock
and we basically got up at a quarter to
ten and the only reason why that was on
saturday night was because
i had the ufc
that was the only reason we would have
still been there
talking and yelling while we were
sitting there three
people on different occasions two women
and one men
came over and said the same thing to us
like guys
you guys are having a lot of fun
keep it down but they were they were
just
and the waiter would come over he was
like bro you guys are like [__] going
off
i told them the story about
because they all used to live downtown
so we always take the number one bus
they remember all those adventures
louie remembers when i farted and i bank
shot her off the chair they went into
the junkies mouth and [__]
and they also said last night that they
weren't
surprised
when they found out that i was a
comedian
they said that
at the 20-year reunion
2002 that's when they were all talking
about it
i was i think i'd done mad tv by then
and something else
and they were like it doesn't
[__] surprise us you know i asked
them what they had heard over the years
they had heard this
okay
so these guys were my
rock before my mother died i mean
and i mentioned all these names to you
guys i know it's [__] confusing
but that's the child that i was having
you know i always tell people i had a
a tremendous childhood i wouldn't have
it any other way i don't give a [__] i
would bury my mother all over again
to have the childhood that i had it was
it was uh
it was [__] tremendous man
you know we were all tight and then we
became freshmen
and we were all going to play on the
freshman basketball team we all had
plans to start
and uh
you know i [__] uh
the coach didn't like me so i didn't
start
and they were there supporting me they
[__] knew what time it was they saw
me grabbing rebounds
and running cincinnati and but the
coaches didn't dig me and they were
talking about last night that they could
see the
they could see it
you know wearing on me that you know i
had all these expectations to start and
[__]
every other coach thought i was going to
start in here i'm i'm not even getting
into games it was uh
it was really hard on me but they
supported me they stayed my friends
i still remember freshman year we all
went to see uh
[__] richard pryor on the sunset
strip as a team you know
as a group of guys you know like
the team and the guys from mckinley and
downtown and
we were just [__] tight and then uh
after freshman year
not even after after this the season
ended
you know i lost my hope
i kind of had lost
my way a little bit it was rough on me
so i started partying a little more
still no drugs it was just weed
you know
a [__] boons form [__] like that
and then uh
i didn't see them that summer that much
i was still playing basketball
i was still getting ready for jv ball
you know
my confidence was down i didn't know
how they were gonna [__] uh you know
look at me my sophomore year
and then i
got a lung infection i got that paraquad
[__] and that put me in the hospital for
two weeks and uh
i got on september 28th of my uh
of my sophomore year
and uh it was too late like i was
spitting blood they didn't really want
me to run around they wanted me to take
a few months off so
i took my sophomore year off i could
always try out for jv when i was a
junior and maybe come back stronger and
start but then november 8th to 79 that's
two weeks later my mother died
and i remember all those guys come into
my wake and it was very hard and
they tried their best guys
but uh
i was somewhere else and that's
david said last night he goes i saw you
you know i would see them at school
and in the summers i wouldn't see them
and then when i got kicked out of the
benders and i lived uptown i really lost
contact with them and then
that october i quit high school so i
didn't really
see them a lot
and i would see them at high school
functions
and by that time
i was just a walking disaster you know
and i remember
dave said last night it was the last
time
i remember
visit vividly seeing you
was the night of the senior awards
and we had a party afterwards they had a
party in the city at this [__] drug
bar and we got into a [__] war down
there but i'll never forget that i was
really [__] up down there i had eaten
a couple quaaludes and i had drank
and i drank some beers and we got an
eight ball and
i'll never forget that i was outside and
i was kicking some kid
and that's when i realized my foot was
bleeding like every time i walked
from the heel being soaked with blood
and uh
i'll never forget that i was the cops
had pulled me off the kid and they're
like go home go home
and i said something to one of the cops
he wanted to hit me with a stick or
something and it was dave
it was dave who came over and he goes
coca go home
and when he looked at me
i could see that
either he was looking at me because i
was cooked out or maybe i was bleeding
from my head or something like that
last night he told me he goes that night
when i saw you
i could tell that you were gone
you were a different person
the basketball had a fact that you your
mother's death had affected you and the
drugs were starting to say that to you
and only one other person has ever said
that to me that i had crazy eyes and
that was my uncle he said when you came
here in 84
your eyes were [__] crazy and that's
what this guy said he goes i grabbed you
for a minute and said coco come with us
are you okay and the way you walked away
from i could tell that we had lost you
that's that's why last night they were
like you have no idea how special
this is to us because at the 20-year
reunion we talked about it 2002 which at
that time i really i really wasn't
touring i think i was doing a couple
things with joe rogan but there was no
twitter you know you can get your tour
dates out it's not like it was joe rogan
with special guests that was a [__]
feature act what did i care
so last night before we left we uh
just made a promise that we're gonna get
to do this once a month and not lose
contact
and uh we're gonna try to add people you
know like want to try and do the next
one with chucky and the next one with
you know get like pip get up you know
just get it up to like 20 of us that are
still around you know
i just found out last week also that one
of the girls in that class has leukemia
i called her up at the hospital says
he's having a hard time reading text
messages and [__]
so she goes just hit me up once a week
and i'll text you back so
that's what we've been doing and you
know what man
listen i'm doing great guys i've been
really adjusting
great i got a good future the [__]
book is done i'm [__] excited
i spoke to the agent on saturday and he
said that he loves the [__] book that
only he's got a
few notes at the end and for the
afterward
so was handing this in so my point is
you know
i was doing great i was all along
you know we all struggle if i tell you i
don't struggle from time to time what
type of man would i be i'm bullshitting
you
last week's struggle whatever
whatever i needed in my life
since i moved here
the people that i told joe rogan when
joe's like come to austin
and i go nah dawg i got to be close to
the family
and he goes but joe you don't have no
family i go that's not what you that's
not what i'm talking about i got to be
closer to my family
these are the guys i was talking about
these guys know me
you know three four years before my
mother died they knew what my character
was about
they knew i was [__] [__] heart when
i played basketball i would bite you i
didn't give a [__]
and they knew my
desire to be a [__] savage they knew
that i wasn't lazy
they knew that you know i used to walk
here while i was always hustling
and just uh
listen the biggest gift that we have in
our lives the biggest gift that anybody
can give you
is the gift of friendship
just being your friend they don't have
to give you a [__] car they don't
have to suck your dick you know which
once you come to the conclusion that
somebody's your friend
it makes your life a lot easier you know
i have been
through the [__]
i have been through the [__] mill
the last
40 years you know and uh
from time to time i thought about these
guys once i got back here i really
thought about him like whitey's sister
would always come to my comedy shows
but she lives here white lives in long
island so
it was always like she would call whitey
too late to talk about my comedy shows
but you know what man i made uh i made
my friends really proud
i'm proud of them louisa [__] social
worker
dave's an engineer why he owns his own
construction company
they're all successful they've had their
trials and tribulations
just like me and uh
it was a real pleasure to go out with
them
last night and while i was sitting there
i was looking at him and i'm like
these were the three guys
i was talking about when i made that
statement
and i didn't talk about taking over the
world as like showing up by che guevara
and fidel castro and going into the
hills of new jersey and taking over new
jersey no
i'm talking about if there's something
that i wanted to do now that i had
doubts about before
now it's possible
because i got my balls back attached to
me
these guys were exactly what i needed
to come back into my life i was missing
something
because i've always said all i need
right now is like 10 hours a week to get
filled that's it
with these guys and guess what all three
of them were saying at dinner all four
of them
they were all going you know what man
we have no friends i'm like
how the [__] don't you have friends like
we go to work
we talk to people at work we have
acquaintances
so i said [__] it from now on we're
going to become family whitey's mother
still alive
david's family's still alive it's
[__] me they're in their 80s [__]
whitey's grandfather's still alive he's
like 98 or something like that
so
it was a [__] great weekend listen
guys
you know me you know i love
better help i [__] love them
uh in fact let's do a read for them when
i got him cause it's a monday [__]
afternoon and you need your little read
or monday morning
i love better help the joint is
sponsored
by better help online therapy listen
relationships takes work
a lot of us will drop anything to go
help somebody
we care about but how often do we give
ourselves
the same treatment i got like three
friends that they're always [__]
involved in other people's lives but i
ask them what are you doing for you shut
the [__] up better help online therapy
wants to remind you to take care of the
most important relationship that you
have the one you have with yourself
listen guys i was struggling for a long
time
i didn't know what the [__] was
bothering me
i talked to a friend they said the
contact better help to contact the lady
dana
i did that i told her what i was going
through and you know what here i am
today
eight months later [__] tip top magoo
i'm feeling great so i don't we always
say that therapy can't help us therapy
can help you i learned my [__] lesson
you know it takes it
it takes a big man to [__] tell
people they made a mistake i made a
mistake all those years i wish now i
would have been talking to somebody but
hey
why cry over spilt milk whether it's
hitting the gym or making time for a
haircut or even trying therapy
you're the greatest asset so invest time
in yourself like you do with other
people
better help is online therapy than
office video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist if you
don't want to be on camera you don't
have to be it's much more affordable
than in-person therapy
and you can be matched with a therapist
under 48 hours
give it a try and see why two million
people have used better help online
therapy including your uncle joey
the joint is sponsored by betterhelp
and listeners get 10 percent off their
first month at betterhelp.com
diaz
that's betterhelp.com
[Music]
diaz i love about how
i've been talking to him for like seven
eight months and uh when i first got on
the phone with him i was a little
apprehensive you know
oh for years you see people doing
therapy with like a [__] watch and
[__] and you're sitting on a couch you
know
you know
so i i didn't even know what therapy was
so when it became available to me
i called them and uh
we broke down my anxiety from a to z you
know so
if you're struggling with anything and
listen a lot of people are struggling
the last two years took its toll on this
country a lot of people are struggling
so don't think you're the odd man
[__] out there's a lot more people
struggling than what you [__] think
so try out betterhelp.com code [__]
diaz so
i'm back now guys i'm very happy that uh
i went out with them because you know me
i missed the [__] uh
canceling i thought about it and i was
like ah it's gonna suck i'm gonna feel
weird
it was completely opposite i felt
[__] alive
so uh
depend on your friends more guys i mean
over the pandemic we've lost contact
with a lot of people we're not used to
doing what we were doing
it's a whole new [__] world you know
the last two years [__] everybody up i
was talking to mike when he came here i
even think
i still have a little couple covert
issues i really don't in the back of my
mind but at times when i get invited to
something like that now it's like listen
do i really want to [__] be there you
know
after the last two years can you imagine
going to like a church thing and getting
covered and dying how pissed are you
when you're on the table going [__] i
should have mind my business instead of
prayer from the house so you never want
to be that guy it's like going to a
concert it's like going on country
concert getting shot in the head when
you're laying there going [__] you know
what the [__] was i thinking didn't they
shoot like 80 people in vegas two years
ago what the [__] it's the same thing so
over the pandemic like a guy like me
worried about like going down like how
much is it how important is it for you
to be down there is it worth dying are
you like nah they weren't dying so
i think
that that [__] with us a little bit
and now it's time to move forward guys i
mean you have no idea how happy i am to
move forward now in my head this is done
over
the pandemic is over putin [__] got
rid of everything
putin beats up on the ukrainians and
[__] cobra disappears who knows
what's gonna happen
i'm not happy about the war but i'm not
gonna be
some hollywood celebrity you know i'm
not a [__] celebrity i'm a dirty
[__] comic i'm worried about the war
i pray for them move the [__] on what do
you want me to do go over and put my
army hat on i'm a [__]
60 year old fat dude what am i going to
do i support them my heart goes out to
them i don't know what the [__] is going
on
i hope it ends [__] quickly
i want to have a good summer you know
what i'm saying i don't have to go out
to the beach and [__]
think the russians are coming or the
cubans are coming or we're gonna have
another cold war who the [__] knows i
don't know you don't know anymore we go
day to day now guys that's what the
monday morning podcast is about to
remind us of our [__] boundaries our
strength our weaknesses we're going day
to day i'm still going [__] day to
day i got a busy day today i gotta go to
jiu jitsu i gotta do some maths for
draftkings i gotta do a couple [__]
things because march madness
is in the [__] air and i can't
wait i think the teams get announced
this week
this is the last thing in sports is
[__] baseball's going on strike now
they talk who gives a [__] anymore guys
just worry about yourself i'm happy you
tuned in today
i wanted to get this night off my chest
that
i had a great time in more ways than one
and guys
after the last 22 years in l.a
surrounded by all those [__] artists
and insincere people it was really nice
to just feel like your [__] home and
i've been waiting two years
for for me to say to you guys that i'm
home
guess what [__] i'm home
and that's it for a beautiful [__]
monday morning
the seventh the [__] march it's
gonna be a great week
uh what else is going on i got nothing
going on that's it
what that's my brother's birthday oh
[__] happy birthday
happy birthday scotty but besides that
we're done and done have a great [__]
monday stay black and i'll see you
[__] wednesday morning tip
top magoo
all right you bad [__] i hope
you enjoyed the little
my little [__] saturday night dinner
at steakhouse 85
i loved it if you ever go to [__] new
brunswick to catch the stress factory
make sure you get yourself a nice little
steak but hey the joint is brought to
you by better health online therapy
listen
everything takes time it takes worth a
lot of us to drop anything to go help
some [__] stranger but when we need
help ourselves
we fall short we don't invest in
ourselves it's time to invest in
yourself i know you're going to the gym
i know you're doing your writing i know
you're working out you're eating good
but listen
it's time that you really look into
yourself you're the greatest asset so
invest time and effort into yourself
like you do for all these other stupid
things
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
have to see anybody if you don't want it
it's much more affordable and in person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours
give it a try and see why over 2 million
people have used better health online
therapy
the joint is sponsored by betterhelp and
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com
diaz that's
asked the betterhelp.com
to give you help she's helped me out
tremendously better help is the way to
go i want to thank better help lucy
doc co and liquid iv the best
for sponsoring the joint this weekend
and i want to thank you guys for always
listening and having my back i love you
[__] stay black have a great
day
and i'll see you guys wednesday the
ninth tip top
[__] magoo
so